[Musique]
on sentirait presque les embruns et les
crêpes mais un bagad est loin des
clichés breton celui-ci et saint
quentinois et joue depuis 2013 c'est de
la musique traditionnelle qui
éventuellement adapter on trouve ou de
soi ça fait partie du patrimoine courant
soit ont retrouvé dans des répertoires
comme ce qu'on appelle tony au brésil
elle donc est un ensemble de morceaux de
partition qui ont été collectés en
bretagne et qui ensuite sont adaptés
pour faire de la musique de bagad en dro
en d'ordre au casa bars sont à leur
répertoire
quarante musiciens composent ce bagad un
professionnel de penn sonneur et des
amateurs passionnés
je suis breton par ma mère de coeur
comme beaucoup de gens à partir des
années soixante quinze avec à l'actuel
et le tous les groupes bretons se sont
mis à vulgariser la musique bretonne
plusieurs répétitions par semaine pour
accorder cornemuses bombardes et
percussions et environ trois concerts
par an une manière aussi de rappeler que
les yvelines ont un peu de sang breton
[Musique]